- There is no such thing as a superfood.
There are a lot of foods
that are super good for you,
and that's fine, but this title
of superfood is completely made up.
The notion of a superfood
is that is so good for you,
it will prevent cancer
and even treat cancer
or stave off evil illnesses,
but food alone cannot do that.
When we talk about superfoods,
primarily we think of berries,
foods with high antioxidants.
And it's really a misnomer.
There is no such thing.
There are foods that are good for you
and foods that are not so good for you,
but the idea of a superfood treating
or preventing an illness is false.
Superfoods have evolved,
and they may not have
been called superfoods,
but even back in the 1970s
there were the quote-unquote health foods
which were really the
superfoods of their day,
which included pasta.
- New Catelli pasta.
It's made with a nutritious
blend of unbleached flour.
Catelli adds vitamins too.
- Which is now considered
this horrible gluten-filled,
carb-filled evil with sugar in it.
Bran muffins, which are
really just like small cakes,
were considered superfoods.
Other things, such as frozen yogurt,
was considered a superfood
in the '80s and '90s
because it was healthier than ice cream.
- [Announcer] Delicious
TCBY nonfat frozen yogurt.
What a great tasting way
to help you lose weight.
- Although it does have
pretty much as many calories,
as much fat, and as much sugar.
So superfoods of one day
are gonna be different
from superfoods down the line,
but they're not
necessarily much healthier.
I think a lot of the superfoods
of today are the things
that are hard to pronounce.
So the harder it is to
pronounce, the better it is.
so something like turmeric or quinoa,
a lot of the berries, goji
berries are a new one.
We talked about blueberries
and raspberries a few
years ago being superfoods.
Now we have acai as another superfood.
Again, these are harder to pronounce.
Those are sorta the newer superfoods.
I think as far as should we
be eating a certain superfood,
are we missing out?
Not necessarily.
I think, again, if you wanna eat healthy,
eat berries, eat healthy
grains, eat a balanced diet,
and that will give you enough
nutrition, antioxidants,
vitamins as any superfood would give you.
People have the false notion
that if they're eating a lot
of superfoods in high quantities
that that will keep them healthy
and they don't need to do other things
to take care of their health.
So if you're eating a lot of superfoods
but you don't get a flu vaccine,
that doesn't mean you're
not going to get the flu.
If you're eating a lot of superfoods
and you don't get basic cancer
screening based on your age,
that will not prevent cancer.
So I think there's some
danger in eating superfoods
in that you think that that's going
to be the be-all, end-all
of your healthcare.